ladies that was stanky i mean it's good
look at us making big moves with major
players
alf's gonna write us a hit teens will
tick-tock to it
like
charlie emilio figure it out see you
later baby vibes bro
[Laughter]
did you have a sex guest in my
four-year-old's room
max crawls into your bed every night at
midnight i texted cray at midnight 15.
where did you meet someone named craig
at the instagram wall in the vape lounge
of the sriracha museum
it's a very spiritual place does he know
how old you are
do you know how old you are dawn's song
was just embarrassing reminds me of the
time dan cortez showed me his poetry
you know i um i don't understand this at
all but uh
oh good luck to you too i guess thank
you
see craig nick doubted our thang because
what he doesn't get is that
[Music]
um
what is happening this is for tick-tock
we'll have music and graphics later who
is he that's my twin brother ray and
that's my twin brother cray
and together we're cray this whole thing
was a 48 for 48 challenge
a prank to see if we could get an older
woman to date us for 48 hours without
her noticing
oh my god cray i stand you guys
i love the one where you give ambient to
a bunch of first responders
thanks little ho everyone said it was
impossible especially our girlfriends
cause
we had tried it with a bunch of other
ladies who knew right away but you never
did
you're a straight-up narcissist wiki
but we had sex how dare you nah man
we never touched you
[Applause]
i have been told that my sexuality is
slightly performative
wiki roy you got craze
you have to meet stevia but don't touch
her she's not vaccinated
oh my god you guys this new brody
jenner's ex-wife's palgasm palette
has me super sad face that i only have
one mouth stevia
well that tickles ruins oh i'm so sorry
baby
um mommy's friend don brought you
something to unbox wow i thought you
were like
four tops cause time is fast now
thank you but if you want me to show
your product on camera
you really need to go through my reps
yeah
ladybug you know what i am pumped as
punch
to feel the love from whoever is here we
love you
wiki cease and desist [ __ ] wiki we
see you lady i see you too
fellas so i need to tell the sound booth
what are you singing oh we're debuting
our new song
and she's a banger new song
no this is why too gay
upon on a thing i'm not old enough to
know what it is people are here for
nostalgia
and because our fog machine is said to
have healing properties it's fine
we'll make it work i'm a lip sync
influencer i lip sync to diva is going
off i've done
all the classics katherine heigl losing
it on a script supervisor on state of
the affairs
wendy williams dressing down to cbs self
checkout machine
i wrote the karen wayne bombs did both
sides of the david o russell lily tomlin
fights
whoever they are but then last month
i was panning deep in a community
theater subreddit and struck
goldie weed
no stop the masking
i see you i see you lady
cease and desist when you snap a photo
of my performance you disrespect me
you disrespect the work you disrespect
sir james eugene carey
[ __ ] my lip sync blew up gay
twitter i got a verified check and now
i'm a spokesman for cbd pacifiers
bless shopping on raisinets like it's
your identity
your wet mouth disrespects the work of
our director
the recently deceased richie targens and
your leather pants noises disrespect the
theater
take them off cut them off with the
multi
tool from the truman show
[Applause]
[ __ ] see
so that's why that phrase sounds so
iconic
i invented it
[Music]
come on
[Applause]
it is christmas time step so dec the
halsey
and for some of you happy rihannica
why don't we just say happy holidays or
dabby
holla night can't watch this oh god
[Music]
you